So I'm approaching and I bind the sequence tens of thousand of letters away.
>> And even though she's that far away from the start of the gene,
it's okay, because DNA can fold as we saw just a second ago, and now,
her sequence is actually really close to the beginning of the gene or the
TATA-box region here. So if I'm a
protein that promotes transcription, what am I called?
>> Well, a sequence that promotes transcription
here at this site would be called
an enhancer. Now, not all sequences have to promote
transcription. Some of them inhibit transcription, and we call
those sequences silencers. Now, If we know that the
effect of an enhancer or a silencer is because
of whether or not the protein is bound or
not. I want you to look at the following
scenarios, and tell me which scenario matches with which
level of transcription. This could be a little tricky.
So focus on each picture, and see if you can
match which ones belong to each other. Match the scenario
on the left with the amount of transcription expected on
the right. There are three scenarios here on the left,
three scenarios on the right. The ones on the right
are lettered A, B and C. Just put the letter
in the box that corresponds to the situation on the
left, where you'd expect that situation to be a match.